[Music]
today we honor the legacy of dr martin
luther king jr but republicans say many
of the policies from the far left are
dividing america dr king's niece alvita
king joins us now and alvida we just
want to point out that at the martin
luther king memorial here in washington
d.c your cousin martin luther king iii
just laid a wreath in honor of his
father and your uncle and i'm wondering
on this day when we honor mlk's life and
legacy what are you thinking
john it's good to greet you and to take
that particular question
on the celebration of the birthday of
reverend martin luther king jr my uncle
and my cousins are celebrating in their
own way his children
he and mrs coretta scott king had four
children and three of them are still
living for me i think it's very
important to celebrate
the ministry of reverend dr martin
luther king jr many people forget that
he was a preacher and a prophet so it is
appropriate to celebrate those things he
believed in
human kindness human dignity the
sanctity of life learning to live
together as brothers and all that as
sisters and not perish together as fools
some of his messages were about faith
hope and love so
i remember him as a preacher and a
prophet even before he was that very
great civil rights leader that we know
today
you know mlk once said hate paralyzes
life love releases it hatred confuses
life love harmonizes it hatred darkens
life love illuminates it yeah you
believe that there's too much division
in this country these days and people
aren't listening to those words
there is so much division and it breeds
hatred confusion and fear whether or not
we are arguing who had a kova shot who
didn't why did you take it why didn't
you take it or
what color is your skin if your skin
color is different from mine then you're
racist or i'm a victim all of that is
human
those are human concerns and human
issues reverend dr martin luther king jr
answered with the word of god he said
i've decided to stick with love hate is
too difficult a burden to bear god is
love so people ask me tell us something
about martin luther king jr that we
don't know one of my favorite quotes of
his and it's not often quoted if it ever
is
he said and i'm paraphrasing if the
world
were to fall apart today i would still
plant my apple tree in other words he
was always prepared to serve to help to
reach out the good samaritan story
was one of his favorite sermons and he
did ask a question he never said what
would happen to the man who had been
broken and beaten and robbed and thrown
on the side of the street if i don't
help him what will happen to me and my
soul i don't know if i don't stop alvita
thank you so much for your recollections
on what would have been his 93rd
birthday appreciate it great to see you
thank you so much i'm steve ducey i'm
brian kill me and i'm ainsley earhart
and click here to subscribe to the fox
news youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis